yo what's up Ryan right Veronica six
toes here right ah way to commit Murray
way to commit alright so we're gonna
watch the trailer today for the valid
ook everyone's heard of this movie
apparently I don't know anything about
it it's a horror film
she hates bar I remember one time we saw
the Last Exorcism of Emily Rose together
she was a little freight so she would
hold on to my arm sometimes and I would
flex but there was nothing there nothing
I was like I need a weight lift so I
left there was nothing there oh there
was something there you know what I mean
then my boner would go down during every
exorcism sing actually let's watch this
[Music]
you can't get rid of
a rumbling sound then three Chinooks who
reads these horrible books of children
that's when you'll know he's around you
see huge October everyone's heard of
Jennifer I think Bad's gonna happen to
him did he think that about my dad
before he died
these things are that one I promise to
protect you if you promise to protect me
[Music]
the way has significant behavioral
problems this monster thing has got to
stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't have to define you know just a
big stress to them all children
Seamonsters reports and then stalking my
child
[Music]
[Music]
Wow she's scary too
[Music]
[Music]
dude that looks terrified looks scary I
got some major chills I got chills
Murray
it's my quote - Marie that was I don't I
try not to why it's your catchphrase
it's are you okay really you're mad at
me for making you yeah it's funny how we
do like two horror movies in horror
movies like do nothing but inflict
terrible things so that's the much about
that dream tonight I have bad dreams off
of it really no happened yeah not even
just an off of like somebody's saying
something scary there's a giant penis
roaming the streets killing people
just imagine giant penis with like
really stumpy like man it's like really
[Music]
yeah you kind of like a mascot or
something that does like this is such a
great card - anyway the babadook inspire
the giant penis horror film that we're
gonna write the star Veronica dude only
Veronica can stuff a giant penis
what you doing yeah thank you guys for
recommending that does look scary I want
to check it out if you're new to the
channel um you know we should do
subscribe that's what you should do that
sounds good
right listen to the woman listen to the
woman I need that one yeah if you don't
listen a woman
bad things happen like the babba do
comes after you I won't argue with that
just let this sink in
we're good this was a special request if
you haven't seen the haunted trailer
episode that I we did that these two
were even featured and dedicated to a
special boy out there named tanner
this guy's 12 years old and watches my
stuff he's 12
oh I mean it's horrible with you know
like we're still prank for you buddy
you're still getting a lot of support
out there I didn't know 12 year old
Channel I feel like I you should be a
little more I'm like how am i
influencing this Twitter shout-out to
you yeah for being so chilled and to the
sister hi such a douche for not knowing
your name but anyway Tennant really
wanted me to watch the trailer so yeah
thanks buddy
you're the great special shadow will and
Kaitlyn so to my sister Kaitlyn I
haven't seen her in like really in years
and years and years I had no idea what
happened to her but we reconnected
Kaitlyn and will we're on YouTube they
were watching it and they found me here
and this is like the first contact we've
had since we were little children and my
father stole them away to come to Alaska
so this is really important to me like I
love you to my siblings and I miss you
so much and I'm gonna be coming out
there to the North Pole real soon to see
you wow that was probably the best show
it was a really sincere show yeah yeah
usually I just insult this thanks for
sharing
thanks for sharing yeah I know you
didn't expecting that mapa Lazaro yo kid
how's it going pretty also 12 middle
school for me was awesome man sucked one
time in middle school I took all the gum
from under everyone's desks put it into
his giant ball and I chewed it shut up I
did that yeah did they got a laugh and
then I looked at this girl named Vanessa
who had a
croissant and all I saw was a look of
disappointment why would you make me
remember something like that malar Ezra
what the [ __ ] man do ya did you really
do that
I really did that yeah seventh grade
I'll never forget that yeah how do you
think I got through that sounds like a
villain from like a Batman thing like
Ra's al Ghul that's cool man or it
sounds like a concert I would love to go
to that music festival yeah get tickets
rule you want to take this next one B
Jordan Jackson you say that if he
doesn't give a shout-out your balls will
come off and you are awesome I think you
misread it he said my balls didn't say
I'll take your balls off PS I'm also
saying that he was so awesome deserve my
balls
I'm sure yeah so I can keep my nuts
thanks for saying I'm awesome in the
same sentence that's that's kind of
manipulative isn't it your manipulator
that's what you are what's your skill
manipulation manipulation I convince
people to rip their own balls off
especially near gun AR that's a cool
name the way we're done in your name
your goon your gun I'm calling your gun
sound like you're probably Indonesian my
friend I think your Indonesian are you
Indonesian how much I don't know like
jack about Indonesian names I know one
Indonesian girl her name is Dan think of
a different D and E okay I'm not even
sure if I'm say it's di here I thought
you were talking to Diane maybe I
thought you were talking about Japanese
Deana no Japanese we don't talk about
Japanese Deann around some coffee racism
like I'm not you know people say
everyone's racist a little bit
one's a little bit racist sometime you
look good in glasses she makes a cute
nerd oh yeah I know what I'm gonna think
about later on tonight if I keep looking
at him he says that he gets really
uncomfortable yeah is this right kiss
you